Florida Governor Rick Scott joins us now
from the state's Emergency Operations
Center in Tallahassee governor Scott
good morning good morning this is a
massive storm a hundred and eighty miles
our speed we're worried about storm
surge I'm doing my best to make sure
everybody has fuel I talked to the White
House yesterday talked to secretary Rick
Perry at Department of Energy we're
doing everything we can to get gas into
these stations so people can evacuate
governor I know you just received a
briefing this morning what's the latest
on this storm and where it's headed well
as you just heard there it's a cone we
don't know if it's going to hit the west
coast or the East Coast we so
everybody's got to get ready we do know
that it's going to be massive wind we do
know there's going to be rain but my
biggest concern is people don't
understand the amount of potential storm
surge this couldn't cover homes and we
just haven't seen this we didn't see
this in Andrew and we haven't seen this
so I think people have to really
understand you've got to listen to your
local officials this storm surge can
kill you what can you do to make sure
that those concerns are being people
being responsive and therefore
evacuating what more can the government
do enough sure what we're doing is I
travel the state I was down the keys
yesterday the Miami then down the Naples
area I'll be traveling today around the
state to get the message out I'll be
talking to we do calls with all the
emergency management teams around the
state but I've been tell telling
everybody you've got to listen to your
locals if they say evacuate get out then
don't wait because our highways are
going to get busy where are we seeing
more traffic coming through all the way
up through 75 and 95 so get ready be
prepared have a plan and get out when
they say you can say to get out you said
it best yesterday governor houses can be
rebuilt lives cannot I hope people are
listening to you again thank you so much
sir for joining us this morning thank
you